there's a lot of
unnecessary suffering going on just
because people
believe the wrong things they believe in
pills who believe in medicines they
believe
depression cannot be tackled they
believe you cannot enter into your brain
and i tell you we found a way to get
back to yourself
but get back to mother nature within us
and make some sense within yourself
you are the one who is able now to make
yourself
happy strong and healthy and that is
entering in all those systems just by
by your mind we we are showing this
through
science but do you need science when i
already show this in science with
data scientific results brain scans no
speculation
i tell you but it takes time for
publishing and
and to get it into books and to get it
in mainstream i
tell you here and right now if you just
believe
and and breathe and take a cold shower
for
for god's sake because it's good for
your blood system
then you will become a in the ability to
realign
with the control within yourself to
become happy strong and healthy
to to control your mood and your energy
management
and all look it otherwise up because
it is simple very effective it's here
right now so
my message to you is just breathe and
believe
i think there is a global tendency now
which is looking for answers which is
looking for
new things today it's a it's like a
general way of thinking
that the past did not it's not going to
make it for the present
situation we have too much stress too
much uh uh
autoimmune diseases cancer depression
we are not happy anymore we cannot
guarantee
this uh happiness strength and health to
our children what's happening
with the love so yeah that love
within the native people they lived much
more in
in harmony with nature and we thought as
westerners to take them over
colonize them and all that but now we
are
looking at the dead end we actually need
to go back to
uh become in harmony with nature doesn't
mean we go
live in tepees and wig ramps and uh
caves and all that
we got these big buildings etc but
don't forget if we are able to shoot to
the moon
and not to become happy strong and
healthy then
we got some place to visit was there
ever a time in your life where you lost
belief in yourself
whoa that many times i've
encountered almost you know death
and then i'm losing it
how do you come back from that type of
experience yes yes
how do you retrain your your body and
your mind just believe in the next
record the next
adventure yeah actually very quick
an example for example is the first time
i had to
do a record with the guinness world
records
swimming under the ice say 50 meters
one hole here one hole there one meter
of ice and then breath hold freezing
waters
beyond the polar circle situation and
then the day before i had to do the
actual record
i went in i had no goggles on i lost
away
because i lost a sight
it got frozen the corona the retina
and i lost it i did 113 meters
you couldn't find the hole and i
couldn't find it oh my gosh
i almost uh no i i
in the end i fainted it but
i did not feel any agony
and i felt actually quite peaceful uh
after minutes and minutes under the eye
swimming
you exhaust your body and i got
this narrowed vision boom yes
seeing that that's physiological wow and
then i went on swimming
it was all okay it was like i was
swimming into the death
uh on consciousness and then somebody
grabbed me
a a diver and he brought me back to the
50 meter hole
which i lost you kept going past the
hole yeah yeah i i i i deviated yeah
completely off yeah and it was the
rehearsal so
the diver was i'm not underneath the
eyes
he was still up there but uh hey
i was for minutes too much too long then
it what is it
under the ice wow that that's a moment
so how did you come back from that how
do you train your mind to believe in
yourself again
um at that moment i actually had 100
i i i overcame the the fear of death
of dying there was no agony that's
strange
and uh that's past my perception of what
i thought
it was death you know fear and this
nobody wants to die is that
maybe it's much more beautiful out there
huh well in the afterlife and now we
gotta live
i always say i'm not afraid to die i'm
afraid not to live
you know quotes and things but based on
experience
and so i i i really defied
death and the fear for death over there
not defying like i did it no it happened
and
i learned from it to take away my fear
for death
so and then the other day i only had to
do 50 meters
which was a piece of cake a couple of
butterfly kicks and you're there huh
that's it came out happy yeah yeah
okay that was my number one
uh i like it record do you face fear now
when you go into some extreme challenge
or in any part of your life
a good question any part of their life
because it's all about alive
um actually no my i'm a man on a mission
no fears
oh no no no no i'm a man on a mission
i want to take away fair you know
irrational fears
traumatic fears fears created because
you
do not handle mental issues as grief
emotion ptsd trauma
depression those things we are going to
tackle and somebody's got to do this and
i should have no fear
to accomplish that you know a man on a
mission should not think in me
in fair he should go and accomplish his
mission
yeah and be focused so there i am
i feel like everybody because it's
natural too
you feel fear failures are you said no
no i fear uh i feel
you fear like everybody which it doesn't
hold you back from moving forward
absolutely not come on man it's a much
too important what does it take in the
brain what kind of control
does it take from the brain the mind
over the body to go into extremes as
i've been shown
like going climbing mount everest to the
death
zone in shorts or going record distances
under the ice or standing for two hours
in eyes directly contact
what kind of mind control do you need
to be able to do that that's what i
learned to do through trial and error
just by following my feeling so i felt
good
and good good feeling is like connection
connection of the mind over the body
that feels good that actually is a way
to learn to bring up your psych
controlled
and that is what is needed in a very
extreme situation
wherein ice water is taking place
but actually i took the ice water
environment
to learn to deal with my mind in
connection with the body
tell us about the first time you decided
to jump into an ice cold
i was 17. i also began just because i
felt this urge within myself there is
more between heaven and
and earth i didn't know what but i was
driven
to find out that's the way it all starts
with the intuition with an instinct
[Music]
something inexplicable drives me
so before i when i was 12 years i was
already into psychology books
and i was into karate and yoga and all
those things
anything i could have get my hands upon
i was doing it so at 17 i was really
like a ripe
fruit to get into the depth
and that's what happened when i a sunday
morning
i was outside i saw a thin layer of ice
on the
water i looked around because i had to
undress myself and
nobody around sunday morning easy like
sunday
no going into the water and i
felt from the inside this is it
you you feel it at only one minute
and it gave me a rush and so the other
day i
came back to see if it was repeated and
yes
and you know what happens in the
beginning i was really
i did not really feel the cold i became
aware i didn't feel the cold that it was
like it was playing around with the
with their eyes that was the first uh
very
remarkable thing to me it's not cold
that is actually in a natural capacity
of hours
to deal off the body to be able to deal
with
environment the impact is there
so from there i started became aware
that
if i began to breathe like this deeper
oh my body got charged and
uh i don't recommend this for anybody
but i was doing breathing exercises in
the water
at ease and at a certain moment in just
a couple of months or two
i could stay for five to seven minutes
under the ice
every day no problem very controlled
don't do it if he cannot control this
yeah
yeah learn gradually to learn to ox
energize the body so much
in harsh environment that you become so
tranquil like a baby in their womb
under their eyes
wonderful deep meditation and that's
what i did every day
if someone is feeling um
sick right now and maybe they have
coronavirus maybe they just have the flu
or some type of cold or something else
maybe they're causing sickness because
of the mind and how they're stressing so
much
who knows why what would you say
people should do obviously if they're if
they're sick they should probably
stay quarantined with this practice but
what should they
do in terms of just feeling better to
try to strengthen the immune system
and weaken the sickness what is
something they could do
every day is it 20 minutes a day of
breathing like you said and ice
and doing the ice stuff even if they
feel weak will that help
is it more breathing what's the strategy
to
increase the immune system if they feel
weak then they should do the breathing
exercises
the breathing exercises changes the
chemistry
brings down the inflammation and when it
is brought
down through the breathing techniques
not hey
just do a little bit of breathing yeah i
breathe already
all day long no not that way
just follow the protocol which these
guys in the university
also did also those people are humans
so you are a human follow the protocol
and then it will show you will bring
down
inflammation which was weakening the
person
so the person feels weak he brings down
through the breathing techniques
the inflammation then he feels strong
again
he feels connection again and that is
feeling
strong and from there it starts to fight
off the
the sickness yes the inflammation goes
down
with that the sickness and with that he
feels
he has control over
within his immune system at will
again gives confidence and great feeling
that that is one and then from there
then take the a a hot shower take a cold
one
afterwards from 30 seconds to two
minutes
and you're gonna feel even greater
because you
are exercising and activating the
transportation
system of your body and it's all logic
why why does breathing help boost the
immune system
by itself why why is air into your body
and your cells why does that help
yes when we do these breathing exercises
we have shown in the university
they work different than any other
breathing technique
i have been looking up and
i've gone through science to show it
so that it's factual it's factual
this breathing techniques i've been
exercising
randomly by going into cold water
and cold water is a real stress
and when real stress comes and you are
able by
certain kinds of ways of
breathing then those
are breathing techniques that is able to
fend off
the stress of the cold and so
that those breathing techniques after
being
so much in the cold i took home
i began to do those same breathing uh
techniques which i was doing before but
to fend off the cold i i took them home
and began to exercise at home and then
it shows wow this goes deep it
it changes my consciousness it changes
my feeling
deeply i see all the lights i see all
the chakras
i see the enlightenment i see anything
this is a i learned that by going into
a cold water and cold water is merciless
but righteous
is what i always say but it is so it is
my teacher
if it works in cold water it will work
against antivirus and or any bacteria i
love that
and and more so you learn
if you learn how to deal with cold water
which is very stressful
which goes directly into your emotion
you learn also to deal with your
emotion with your mood and this has now
been shown
in the in the brain scans that i'm able
to connect
with the areas where emotion is residing
where while stress is coming upon my
body
i was able to feel euphoria and you
could not miss because you could see the
brain
and within the brain you know where is
the area of emotion
and where's the area of pain and
and sensation and they saw it all and
that was for the first time
all learned in the cold water
then i took that breathing those
those became techniques i took them home
began to do them and it's
amazing what i also and then i went to
the university
and they gave me an injection i began to
do these breathing techniques
and the bacteria had no chance
if you want a marissa peer affirmation
for success video check it out right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there and so a lot of people have
language that's completely irrelevant
like yes
i know your dad left when you was one i
know your mother
put you up